let's talk about alexei navani the man
russian president vladimir putin won't
mention by name
depending on who you are in russia
navalny's a brave anti-corruption
campaigner
standing up to putin and his comrades or
he's a western stooge making trouble
he's been arrested jailed even poisoned
and
now he's back behind bars the russian
opposition leader alexey navalny has
been sentenced to three and a half years
in prison
it's why thousands of russians have been
protesting and getting arrested
so who is alexei navalny what's his game
plan
and should putin be worried
russia is putin's world and everyone's
just living in it
they kind of have to he controls
basically everything the state media
state-run companies a powerful
intelligence network
and his critics say the justice system
too putin's had its political
challengers
but no one's really got the kind of
attention that alexi navani has
navalny started out writing political
commentary online
that's why putin's people dismiss him as
the vlogger
but this is what he's known for
[Music]
there's slick investigative videos about
corruption among
russia's rich and powerful they get
millions of views
there is a great uh concern about the
russian elites um you know spending all
this money
when the last years um the situation of
the economy has not significantly
improved and wages have been stagnating
what hasn't stagnated is navalny's
political ambition
[Applause]
he's organized protests run for mayor of
moscow
and even tried running for president
but it's been a tough fight navani and
his supporters say he's been held back
at every turn multiple arrests for
protesting
and two convictions for embezzlement and
fraud though navalny says he's innocent
and the european court of human rights
had issues with the legal process
one of those convictions even got him
banned from running for president in
2017.
and then there were all the attacks
antiseptic was thrown in his face
he says he was poisoned in jail and last
year someone apparently
tried to kill him again navalny got
really sick on a domestic flight
fell into a coma and had to be
transferred to a hospital in germany
investigators in berlin said he'd been
poisoned with a nerve agent
belonging to the novichok family it's a
soviet-era chemical that russian agents
have been accused of using before
on one of their former spies on his
daughter in the uk
alexei navani blamed putin and russian
intelligence
putin just laughed it off
so he's forced to go to germany to get
treatment but he's still on probation
for one of his convictions
then the russian authorities turned
around and said navalny broke the rules
by leaving the country
which means jail time but that didn't
stop navalny from coming home
boy bring us a little vodka we're flying
home says julia
quoting a much-loved russian gangster
movie it's a nevali hallmark
that he and his family make light of the
many dangers they face
and what he faced was jail on arrival
so why did he return to russia while
navalny says it was about
sending a message that he's not afraid
of putin
he always pretended he is a brave man he
has no fear of putin
that's why if he states abroad well he
diminishes his claims
for his return to mother russia navalny
had something special in mind
another video this time a straight shot
at putin
tragic
it's about a seaside palace that was
supposedly built for putin
though a russian billionaire who's close
to the president recently said it's his
not only this is about corruption this
is about
putin's transformation from great
and very impressive leader into
funny crook that video and navalny's
return
kicked off some of the biggest protests
russia has had in a long
time
they even spread to rural parts of
russia that haven't really had big
demonstrations against putin
destroyed
[Music]
thousands of people have been arrested
navani's wife
his brother and other opposition figures
all of this matters because there are
parliamentary elections coming up in
september
some analysts talk about russia's
political scene being roughly divided
into thirds
one third of people who support putin a
third who oppose him
and another third who aren't sure putin
supporters like the way things are
they even voted for a constitutional
change that lets putin run for president
two more times meaning he could stay in
power until 2036
and many of them don't like navalny they
echo
what the kremlin and state media say
that he basically works for the cia
he is regarded as a political agent
of the russian enemies because of all of
the united states there are other people
who support navani
or just want to vote for someone who
isn't allied with putin
but what about the millions of people in
this section here
there's also one more third that
refrains from politics and
evades politics but maybe uh can't be
mobilized let's be clear putin still has
a lot of support
where navani has the edge is with young
people who use social media
it's a weapon he understands better than
most and mavani's been campaigning to
knock
putin's base for a while his project
called smart voting kind of worked
united russia lost its majority in three
city councils
i think the kremlin is worried that
there could be a sort of
a potential backlash
in the elections although not at a
massive scale but the beginning of a
significant turn
so will navalny's game plan work well
usually you'd measure that at the ballot
box
but russia doesn't have the best record
of free and fair elections
based on an osce report at least we can
claim that he's popular he's not popular
but all of this you know is very hard to
assess
if we do not have an open and effective
system of competition navalny is not
trying to get rid of putin overnight
but he is forcing putin's hand throwing
navani in jail
arresting people cracking down on
dissent it might just backfire
there's obviously a lot more to this
story and stuff is happening in russia
all the time so check our website
aljazeera.com where our colleagues have
lots of analysis
and all the updates i'll see you next
week
[Music]